hey everyone welcome back to teram
Gardens today we're focusing on pepper
that's become incredibly popular in
recent years the Sriracha pepper known
for its role in the famous sriracha
sauce this pepper is spicy flavorful and
must have for hot sauce lovers and
gardeners alike did you know that
Sriracha Peppers while named after the
famous sauce aren't originally from
Southeast Asia in fact they were
specifically developed in the United
States by organic sea producers for use
in making the iconic sriracha sauce
these Peppers offer a perfect balance of
heat and sweetness which is why they're
ideal for sauces stirs and more the
story of sriracha Peppers is a modern
one while the original sriracha sauce
named after the coastal town of sriracha
and Thailand was created using different
local chili varieties the peppers now
commonly associated with the sauce were
developed to meet the growing demand in
Western markets these peppers are often
classified as a high bread of the
jalapeno and cayenne pepper families
since the 1980s sriracha sauce
particularly huong's version has grown
to a global sensation leading to the
popularity of the pepper variety used to
create it so racher pepper plants are
medium siiz typically growing to about 2
to 3 ft tall the peppers themselves are
long and slender usually reaching about
5 to 6 in in length when mature they
turn from a deep green to a bright red
giving them that classic chilly pepper
look the plant is quite productive often
yielding a large number of fruits over
the course of a gor season these peppers
are moderately hot ranging from 2500 to
5,000 Scoville heat units making them
comparable to jalapenos but with with a
slightly more complex flavor profile
Sriracha peppers are relatively easy to
grow provided you give them the right
conditions like most peppers they thrive
in warm sunny environments they require
full sun with at least 6 to 8 hours of
sunlight per day the soil should be well
draining rich in organic matter and have
a pH between 6.0 and 6.8 if you're
starting from seed plant the seeds
indoors about 8 to 10 weeks before the
last frost date the seeds need a warm
environment ideally between 70 and 80°
fhe to germinate once the ceilings are
strong enough and outdoor temperatures
are consistently above 60° F you can
transplant them indoors place the plants
18 to 24 in apart to ensure they have
enough room to grow and produce fruit
make sure to water them regularly
keeping the soil moist but not waterlog
and mulching around the base of plants
can help retain moisture and keep the
roots cool during the hot spells
Sriracha peppers like many chili
varieties benefit from companion
planting ideal companions include basil
carrots and onions these plants can help
deter Pest and even enhance the flavor
of the peppers tomatoes are another
great companion as they share similar
growing conditions and playing them
together can optimize space in the
garden avoid pling Sriracha Peppers near
Fel as they compete for nutrients and
potentially stunt growth one interesting
behavior of the Sriracha pepper plants
is their ability to thrive in containers
making them perfect for patio or balcony
Gardens they are prolific producers so
even a single plant can yield a
substantial Harvest throughout the
growing season these Peppers also
continue to produce until the first
Frost so with the right car you'll have
fresh pepper as well until late summer
or early fall in terms of pest
resistance Sriracha peppers are
generally Hardy but can still attract
common Garen pests like aits and
spidermites regular inspection along
with organic pest control methods such
as neoil can keep these issues in check
Sriracha peppers are of course best
known for their use in making sriracha
sauce however they have many other
culinary applications these peppers are
great in stir fries marinades and Salas
you can also pickle them or dry them to
make chili flakes for seasoning the
moderate heat levels make them versatile
adding a bit of spice without
overwhelming the pette in terms of
health benefits like many Chili Peppers
soracha Peppers contain capsacin
compound responsible for their heat
capsacin has been linked to a variety of
health benefits including boosting
metabolism reducing inflammation and
even promoting cardiovascular health
they're also rich in vitamins A and C
which are essential for immune function
and skin Health Sriracha peppers are a
fantastic addition to any Garden
offering not only their signature spicy
flavor profile but also a long growing
season and plenty of culinary uses
whether you're looking to make your own
hot sauce or just want to add a little
heat to your meals these peppers are a
great choice for both beginners and
experience gardeners alike thanks for
tuning in don't forget to like share and
subscribe for more gardening tips and
tricks and as always happy groin